[Music]
right now america is facing a labor
crisis and
i don't mean the kind where a woman
gives birth in a taxi i mean the kind
where millions of people are out of a
job
at one point during the pandemic the
unemployment rate was at its highest
level
since the great depression but as
america begins to open back
up it turns out not everyone is open to
going back to work
because a lot of people are making more
money on unemployment
than they did at their previous jobs
like a lot
a lot according to one study two-thirds
of jobless workers would make more money
from unemployment
plus the federal government supplement
than they would have on the job
which explains why many americans are
reluctant to return to work
now the media keeps referring to this
situation as a quote
worker shortage but america doesn't have
a worker shortage
we have a shortage of workers willing to
take a job unless they receive a living
wage
our current national minimum wage is
7.25 an hour
that's not a living wage in 2021 and
that wasn't a living wage in 1971
and back then the only things you needed
to pay for were rent electricity
and a pair of these you know it looks
good
pictures are popping up all over the
country of signs posted on businesses
saying they're closed or short-staffed
because quote
no one wants to work anymore happy face
which
by the way is a truly passive aggressive
use of a smiley face
the only worst use would be this
well let me set the record straight all
my life i've heard the same argument
if you don't want to earn minimum wage
get a better job well guess what
that's what people are doing they're
waiting to find a job that respects them
and pays them it turns out the free
market also means that workers are free
to only work at the job is worth it
not just because the job is there can
you imagine going on a date every time
someone asked you just because they
asked and when you asked what you were
going to do on the date they said
make you work until you're 65 but you're
still going to die poor
that's a terrible date do not go out
with them
since the financial crisis of 2008
employers have become accustomed to
paying low wages
so that they can line the pockets of
high-level executives
and just like that other type of labor
crisis the people most affected are
women
during the pandemic countless women had
to leave their jobs to take care of
their children
do you know why because no one else was
going to do it
do you think they don't want to go back
to work i mean
have you ever met a child they will ask
you 273 questions in a row
and then sneeze in your mouth of course
those women want to go back to work
but they need a job that pays them
enough to do it
you can't ask a person to work a minimum
wage job at 7.25 an hour when they have
to pay
20 dollars an hour to get a babysitter
and before you ask
yes that's how much a good babysitter
costs do you think claudia kishi can
dress like this on a budget
until america catches up with much of
the rest of the developed world and
provides viable child care
women are pretty much screwed and not in
the fun way that help them make those
kids in the first place
so from now on don't get mad when you
see one of these signs
get excited people are literally pulling
themselves up by their bootstraps by
demanding to earn enough money to buy
some goddamn boots
and if you're in the middle of this
cluster right now
listen to me you are not lazy you
deserve to be able to work one job that
covers the basic necessities like food
shelter clothes and a subscription to
peacock
i'm just kidding peacock is actually
free you don't even need to enter a
credit card number to sign up just an
email address and a password so do it
but most importantly you deserve to work
in a safe environment with employers who
value your life
oh by the way if you're a business owner
who refuses to pay a living wage and
then complains when no one wants to work
for you
you are not a business owner you are a
plantation owner but your plantation
is a frozen yogurt shop listen we could
be living through one of the greatest
labor movements in history because
knowing your worth is revolutionary
and this is a revolution baby so go get
your money you
earned it
you